so how do you find your niche
on youtube maybe you are just starting
out or
you're wanting to rebrand so you can
build your business and your youtube
channel well my name is heather torres
from think marketing and i am
so excited to share with you the five
steps
for figuring out what niche is right for
you
and if we're just meeting again my name
is heather and today we're talking all
about how to find
your niche on youtube let me know in the
comments
what's your current niche i'd love to
know or are you someone who is
struggling and trying to figure
it out well uh if my name is heather and
um i am part of think media where we
help you build your influence
with youtube we are a team of creators
and we are here to help you do that and
i'm most proud of the students who we've
helped do this already from zero to over
a hundred thousand subscribers
when it comes to picking your niche this
is probably one of the most
important things to do when developing
your youtube
channel and i have a quote for you that
i think is
so important when you think about your
niche you don't want to be a wandering
generality
you want to be a meaningful specific and
let me know in the comments do you ever
feel like picking your niche
actually means you have to be an expert
in something like does the word
expert come to mind when you think about
actually having to
narrow down into one thing to talk about
online
i know for me when i think about my when
i think back on my journey on youtube
it definitely has been a process of
having to
maybe divorce the word expert when it
comes to things like my homeschool
channel and things like that so if
you're struggling right away
with that idea of imposter syndrome or
the idea of
wanting to create content but not
necessarily being an
expert at it maybe you've got some
receipts you've got some results in
something but you haven't yet
necessarily become a quote-unquote
expert in that space
well i want to let you know that you can
actually choose your niche
without being an expert you can actually
think about yourself more like
a friend a guide a mentor or a leader
in that space and i'm excited because in
this video i'm going to be sharing
five steps to help you discover your
niche and i'm also going to be bringing
you examples from video ranking academy
members
think media community members and my
personal friends
who are doing this and crushing it on
youtube
so let's start with step number one
and step number one is to identify your
interests and passions
i'm sure you've heard this before it's
like follow your passion
and everything will fall into place well
that's not necessarily true
one of my passions is hiking and not
that i couldn't necessarily make a whole
business out of hiking
but it's not like the best passion
that i would feel would be right for me
and who i
am so i want to make sure you've got a
journal out you're ready to be taking
notes during this video
because this is one of the things that
really matters understanding what your
interests and passions are
is a lifelong process but you want to
think about this
what is something that i could actually
talk about for the next three to five
years
and that might seem like a really far
stretch like something that you have to
really you know take some time to think
about but the reason that you want to
identify
what your interests and passions are
that you can talk about for the next
three to five years
is because if you know anything about
think media and what we teach here
it's not that we want you to just have a
successful youtube channel
we want you to have a successful
business we want you to
have freedom in your lifestyle and in
your finances and
and to be able to create something that
will impact the world for good and so
when you think about what are your
interests and passions sometimes we
think
way too broad and i want you to bring it
down even
smaller so i just shared with you that
one of my passions is hiking another
passion of mine is tiny homes and
rv life another passion of mine is
homeschooling
i'm also really passionate about helping
people with self-confidence and getting
started on youtube
and so when i think about all the
different passions that i have i need to
really
identify what do i want to be known for
right
now and i think that's key to think
about what do i want to be known for
right now because what you're known for
today
doesn't mean it has to be what you're
known for tomorrow so when you think
about your interests and passions it
makes me think of rachel ray
you know rachel ray is someone i really
admire because i think her cooking is
it looks so beautiful but when you think
about rachel ray and the process that
she went through to get to who she is
today
you know she started with just creating
videos
about uh pasta by creating videos about
italian style cooking and not just
italian style cooking but a specific
type of italian style cooking and over
the years rachel ray
has now developed into someone who owns
physical products inside
of major brand stores she hosts her own
tv show where she's interviewing people
like matthew mcconaughey
you know she's grown from just a person
who was known for italian style cooking
to someone who's actually built an
entire
brand empire and so when you think about
what are your interests and your
passions
i want you to think about what am i
interested in and passionate about right
now
that i could go deep on for the next
three to five
years and one of the examples is
actually myself
you know one of my channels that i have
here on youtube is the homeschool house
this is a channel
all about homeschooling and it's one of
my major
passions and interests i could talk
homeschooling with you
all day long i've read every book on
homeschooling i watch all the videos on
homeschooling i've been
involved in the community i know the
people who are in this community and i
am
so incredibly passionate about
homeschooling now
here's what's totally different about
this channel it's not just a
quote-unquote
motherhood channel i'm speaking to moms
i'm speaking to families i'm speaking to
that audience but i'm even niched
down into just talking about homeschool
homeschool styles reviews of curriculum
a day in the life videos i'm able to
really go
deep into this one niche and be known
for one thing
first before branching out into all
things
motherhood you know i think about sean
who is the ceo
of think media sean was geeking out on
cameras
a decade ago and he's still talking
about them today
why because it's his interests and his
passion
it makes me think of plants of lucia she
has an amazing channel
all about plants i mean could you
imagine
being a plant mom and getting to have an
entire channel about plants
well that's what plants of lucia has
been able to create
here on the platform of youtube so my
question to you let me know in the
comments
what is your interests and passions i'm
sure you're like me and you're
multi-passionate and you have all these
different things that you want to talk
about
but here on youtube you're talking to
two
sets of ears one ear is the youtube
robots themselves that means that you
need to be speaking in a language
that the robot understands that the
algorithm understands where they can
put you in front of the audience who
wants what you
have and the second one is people you
know when you think about
really breaking through if i were to ask
you hey i'm
new to town who who's the best
pediatrician
someone probably comes to mind why
because they've become known
for being the best pediatrician they're
known for something if i were to say oh
man i really need to
uh to do some work inside my house do
you know a handyman who's really good at
installing fans maybe someone comes to
mind they've been known for one thing
so all we're doing is we're taking the
offline aspect
and we're bringing it on line when
you're speaking to two set of ears
you've got to be able to speak
both to the algorithm and the youtube
robots and you also need to be speaking
to
people now if plants of lucia were to
throw out a yoga video
it would be off-brand it wouldn't be in
the same
niche but plants of lucia can go so deep
on all different types of plants
she can be on all different types of
products when it comes to
um plant life she can talk and interview
people she can review books she can
write books there's so many ways that
she can go
but she's interested and passionate
about one thing
on youtube so what do you do with all
the other interests and passions that
you have
you enjoy them you still are a
multi-faceted creator i know this about
you because you want to be successful on
youtube meaning
that you have a drive to be creative
and so what do you do with what do i do
with hiking and rving
and um you know all the passions that i
have that aren't on youtube
i just enjoy them i don't try and make a
profit off of
everything that i love i really stay
focused on the things that matter on
youtube
i stay focused in the niche i'm talking
about on youtube and i live the rest of
my life creative and inspired and
passionate
about so many other things so i'm going
to help you if you have
multi things that you're passionate
about as we go through these different
steps
i want you to really start honing in
more and more on the one thing that you
want to talk about
on youtube and if you're getting value
out of this video already with
tip number one make sure you hit that
like button to make sure you're
subscribed here on think marketing
and everywhere that we are so you see
all of our live shows and podcasts that
we have available for you
to help you grow your business and brand
on youtube
so step number one was identify your
problem it was
identify your passions and interest step
number two is identify the problem
you solve now you might be someone who
wants to be
in the entertainment space this isn't
actually who i'm talking to
i'm talking to you if you are in the
entertain or in the education space
if you are in the edutainment space if
you are in the information space now
it doesn't mean that you can't be
entertaining in what you're doing
but the people that went on youtube the
reason people break out
when they start their channel is because
they are someone who is solving a
problem for someone else
remember at the beginning when i said
you don't necessarily need to be the
expert in the thing
you just need to be a friend one step
ahead on the journey
who's helping the people who are behind
you
you don't have to be the expert you can
be the leader
of a community you can bring people
together and do shared interests and
help people collaborate so when you
think about what problem do you solve
i want you to be hyper focused on the
problem
that you solve and the reason for that
is because people do business
that they they do business with people
that they know
like and trust and if you're here on
youtube and you're building a brand and
you're a part of our think media
community
then again you know that it's not just
about building a youtube channel
it's about building so much more it's
about what that youtube channel can
provide for you which is
time freedom financial freedom ability
to be creative when you want where you
want with the people that matter most to
you
and so we want to figure out what is the
problem that
we solve make sure you're taking notes
and let me know in the comment section
if you're already getting value
but when i think about that i think
about my friend ben from keto camp you
know he just crossed a hundred thousand
subscribers it was so cool
to be able to celebrate that with him
when i think about ben what does he
solve
he's not just talking about diet and
exercise the problem he solves is
helping
people figure out keto he's helping
people figure out how do i do this
lifestyle of keto what does that even
mean and and he can go
so deep on things from cell inflammation
all the way to the best fruits on keto
he has a huge
sandbox to play in when he identifies
the problem that he's solving for people
you know it reminds me of tiffany who's
a part of our video ranking academy
family her and her husband they have a
channel called hammer and home
well what do they do they help you
figure out how to use the tools
and you might think well who needs that
uh
heather needs that okay when melissa
caputo from the think media team and i
decided to renovate an
rv this summer during lockdown um i had
never owned a tool before
so guess whose channel heather was binge
watching
so that i could learn how to actually do
this how could i
learn to actually use these tools and
what tools were the better one is it
this brand or is that this brand right
well tiffany and her husband from hammer
of home are solving the problem
for people who are new to actual
home building or new to actually using
tools
uh also i think about uh chana from
technodad channa
is helping you with your home theater
setups now i don't know if you're
anything like me
but when you walk into best buy home
theater section and you're seeing the
tvs and the
and the sound bars and all the wires and
all the things you're like
um do i have to put all this together
well chana is helping you decide
do i get this receiver or this receiver
should i have these cables or those
cables
should i get this 4k tv or this 4k tv
channa is helping you solve the problem
of understanding your home theater
craziness my friend erica kohlberg she
is blowing
up her channel she has over three
million views and climbing like crazy
with viral videos
she's helping people with personal
finance but she's coming at it from the
side
of her background that she has in how
she was helping in legal and finance
and so she's bringing topics like about
robin hood and explaining the stimulus
checks
from her point of view so what niche
are you in what problem do you solve and
what are you interested and passionate
about
number three if you're getting value
make sure you hit that like button
number three
you want to research your competition
now you might be thinking but heather
i want to do my own thing i've got this
really cool idea
no one's doing it whenever i hear
no one's doing it red flags pop up
everywhere why
because i don't want you to reinvent the
wheel i want you to join
in on the conversation that's already
happening you know there's a book by
seth godin it's called tribes and it's
really about the idea of
there's already a market for where you
want to go you just have to tap into
them
in your own unique way right you don't
want to be a wandering generality
you want to be a meaningful specific so
that makes
me think of my uh friend justin he has a
company here in las vegas called total
dogs their company is exploding
and this year he decided to start his
youtube channel now
he's not at a million subscribers yet
but he was wondering you know
should i even invest in this is it even
the right thing to do for my business
is am i even going to be able to break
through the algorithm and understand
like are people even interested in dog
training online
so what did we do well we just typed in
a few search terms
on youtube to discover that yeah there's
some really successful
channels all in the same niche that he's
in so he can join
the current conversation you know mccain
dogs is actually
one of our students and they're over a
half a million subscribers
just on youtube and not even touching
their actual
brick and mortar business that they have
happening there's zach george who is one
of the
uh the largest ones outside of caesar
everyone knows caesar malone right
well zach george is just a regular guy
who started a youtube channel and
started uploading videos
three million subscribers all he does
now is make videos
on dog training so yeah you want to make
sure you're researching
your competition and here is what
research actually looks like because
let me know if you're anything like me
sometimes re research
more so goes down the line of watching
all my
competitors and comparing myself
do you do this you struggle with this
you start to really get excited about a
niche you want to be in or a topic you
want to talk about one you've probably
never made a youtube video before in
your life
you don't really know how to do youtube
the right way
and then you're gonna go and look at
people who are already successful
so when we're going in and we're doing
research here's what i want you to be
thinking about
man if they can do this i can do it too
man
if there's people right now that are
showing that they can be successful on
youtube i'm just a step behind them
maybe go back and see how long they've
been creating videos on the platform
you know when we looked at zach george
he had been creating videos for eight
years on youtube so you kind of have a
better perspective
of what the journey might feel like i
understand
youtube can feel sensational right
everyone wants the viral video everyone
wants to be
mr beast at 50 million subscribers
but the honest truth is you can have a
successful business
you can have a successful youtube
channel and not even make it to a
hundred thousand subscribers
you could be making over six figures a
year you could quit your day job
you could start to travel with your
family and not even
have to make thousands
of videos i hope you're seeing this here
that
when you go in and you start studying
your competition that it's not about
comparing where you are
to where they are it's about seeing the
inspiration and seeing the future and
being able to put yourself in their
shoes and say
if they can do this i can do this too
zach jordan is just an ordinary
guy who picked up a camera and so i told
justin
you are so many steps ahead you've been
able to be a dog trainer for
decades and now you're just flipping on
the camera
and so i hope that when you go into the
com the competition
uh you want to assess your competition
that you're not comparing yourself
but we want to actually get legitimate
data on is this viable
if you're going to spend your hard
earned time and your harder money
investing in something
well then i want you to be investing in
something that's going to have a return
on your investment so when you're
thinking about what niche you want to be
in
i encourage you to go and study the
competition
what can you join where can you be
another voice
in an already producing market
i hope this is bringing you value and
you're getting lots of insights and
nuggets
we're gonna head into question number
four
which is actually going into what i said
defining
the profitability of your niche
well what does this mean this means that
if you're going to start a youtube
channel
and the end goal is that you want that
youtube channel to be something that
helps maybe
retire you and your spouse maybe give
you the spending money to go on that
vacation
maybe help you pay for your groceries or
um or your car payment like whatever
that thing is for you as to why you want
to do youtube
well let's make sure that it's able to
make money
i mean there's actually not very many
niches that don't make
money but i want you to think about
what's the profitability
of this niche remember if you have a
business
that's not making money then it's a very
expensive hobby
and so when we go into youtube when you
start your channel when you define your
niche
we also want to define well what are the
revenue streams
how can i view this as a business right
when i get started
so there's a couple ways that you can do
this uh when you think about this you
can start with youtube ads
did you know that youtube is the only
platform
that pays you to be a creator now i
understand you could become
a tick-tock influencer i understand that
they do have
other options but long-lasting
residual income coming from actual
videos that you've made
years before still paying you on the
platform
youtube is the company that partners
with creators so you could do that
through youtube ads
one of the youtube uh youtubers that i
follow in the real estate niche
just did a video on how he had 75 000
subscribers
and made over 55 000 in one year
75 000 subscribers he made 55 000
he's creating great content that's
valuable in the real estate
niche and youtube ads are paying him a
full-time salary
in america just from creating content
he actually predicts that with the
investment he's made in his youtube
channel
he'll be at a million dollars in youtube
ads
in just a few years this is possible my
friend
it's knowing what your revenue streams
are from the beginning
there's also affiliate marketing you
know this is actually the story of sean
cannell the ceo of think media
he actually went full time was able to
not have to have any freelance clients
him and his wife were able to fully live
off of youtube ads
and affiliate marketing there is a giant
opportunity for you to not have to
create your own products
just but to be able to partner with
other companies
and help sell theirs and i'll make sure
to link in this video and down in the
description box below
an entire series that we have all about
how to get started
with affiliate marketing there's also
brand deals
there's so many companies right now that
are looking for micro
influencers meaning small channels who
have a great impact on the community
that they are part of uh when i think
about myself uh
with my homeschool channel i was able to
secure a brand deal with less than 10
000 subscribers
that ended up helping us pay for our
homeschool materials they paid me to
create the video
and they gave me stuff for free so i
could create the video
all because they were a company that
wanted to reach the exact audience
that i had so the benefit of being a
meaningful specific is that i'm sure
there are companies
that want to partner exactly with the
people
that you help when i think about erica
colberg she was able to secure
a large brand deal with a company with
less than a hundred thousand subscribers
that pays her
more than she was making at her firm
because
she was able to be a meaningful
specific so you have the opportunity of
brand deals
there's also physical products maybe
you're someone who wants to have a
cookbook in the in the cooking niche or
maybe
like my friend jordan who does
chakootery boards she could be
actually making boards and selling those
from her youtube channel there's so many
options for physical products
when it comes to youtube there's also
digital products
that's actually the way that think media
was able to break into the multiple
seven figures not just from youtube but
because we actually
created an entire educational company
behind
our youtube channel that helps creators
just like you go deeper
and understand how to do youtube right
and it
then a great example of this is an
up-and-coming creator
named cami now cami started the
plant-based kitchen with her husband
tony
and uh they started this channel and
she's at 2 000
subscribers right now but cami has
already broken through to be able to do
affiliate marketing so she
just did vegan kitchen essentials
right she's talking about all of the
products that she loves and uses in her
kitchen
linking to those down below so she's got
affiliate marketing happening
she has youtube ads happening now
because she's able to be at the level to
partner with youtube right she has over
1 000 uh subscribers and 4 000 hours of
watch time
and then on top of that they were at the
local farmers market where they
loved to shop for organic olive oils
they were talking to the person who owns
this olive oil company
and they secured a brand deal and
affiliate marketing with the
oil company because she is using those
oils in her videos are you seeing the
possibility of where this goes
now kami and tony aren't making hundreds
of thousands of dollars it's not
sensationalized
with where it is right now but can you
see the seed
can you see what they can harvest in the
future can you see that this is
proven concept that when you get niched
and you get focused and you put your
energy into one thing
that the possibilities are endless so i
want you to be thinking about how can
this
niche be profitable what are my angles
to be able to do this
and how can i be able to make money off
of my channel
and then lastly number five number five
is you want to test
your idea i know you're probably like
where's the golden nugget heather
well here's the golden nugget my friend
you need to actually start doing the
thing
i know it's scary i know picking one
thing can feel
so uh restricting as a creator
i know that there's a lot of things that
you want to try and you see what other
people are doing
but my friend if you've gone through
those first four steps
if you've made it that far and committed
to what your niche is
then it's time to start testing your
idea and it's not testing your idea with
just
one video or five videos or ten videos
testing your ideas saying no i'm
committed to this i'm committed to
uploading a video a week
for a year i'm committed to learning how
to do youtube right
i'm committed to actually investing my
time investing my money investing myself
my mind and my focus into making this
thing work
because you know what's on the other
side of your testing of your practicing
in public
of you failing forward success
it doesn't happen if you try and do it
sitting and thinking it only happens
with momentum that's where success
happens
and sean always says you know you can't
actually steer a parked car
well how will i know it works you can't
steer a parked car
well what if it doesn't work my friend
you have to actually start driving the
car
you have to get past the sucky part
you have to make five videos and be
excited that you did it you have to put
in the work
to build a content library
it doesn't happen overnight but i can
tell you from seeing this successful
thing happen
over and over with creators just like
you who have been committed to
getting in the driver's seat who have
been committed to grabbing the steering
wheel
putting the key in the ignition starting
the car
and just slowly moving
not pressing the gas pedal and saying
i'm all in because what happens you
crash
no no you gotta like put your blinker on
you gotta look behind you
you gotta slowly push the gas pedal down
and that's all i'm asking you to do if
you want to figure out how to choose
your niche on youtube go through these
five steps and then stay committed
and if you've loved this training so far
we actually have a free
one hour class over at
thinkmasterclass.com
if you want to go deeper on learning how
to do youtube right
where we share one of our case studies
on how we were able to
make money off of one video where you
can do the same exact thing then you
want to go to
think masterclass for
this free class and if you're getting
value again
make sure you smash that like button my
name is heather torres and you are
here on the think channel and we have
some people that are
ready for q a if you want to come on for
q a with me
you can uh melissa from our team has
posted the link
below in the chat so i'm excited i want
to just say
hi to the daily kai the little crafting
nook
ray and kyle um here mao is here
the life with horses merrell hello
thanks for being here
we've got john here my blocks strongest
man is here your driver mike is here
thank you so much for being a part of
this training let me know what your aha
moment was
and i love this this is from crafty uh
crafting
with slavi um the
suck sucks success is exactly right
benazani who i called out in this
training
uh mentioned that on one of our classes
that we had here at think media thank
you for saying that
and i'm so excited for you to be here
i'm gonna take a sip of water real quick
and check out this quick ad for
the think master class are you ready to
start
or grow your youtube channel do you feel
stuck and need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
all righty we are excited i am excited
i'm going to take this off
real quick because i have wendy here
from our think family
how you doing i'm great heather how are
you
i am fabulous wendy i know you're part
of our programs video ranking academy
inner circle
thank you so much for being a part of
that um i know who you are so
my question is and let's dive into it
okay
so my question is directly related to
niches
i have posted notes upon post-it notes
where they the niches all seem to be the
same
on the same level and i have no way to
break the tie
on what to choose i've made some videos
about bible study i've made some videos
about health and wellness
some about starting a online business
and doing some tech tutorials and they
all get me jazzed up to a certain degree
um but i can't figure out a way to break
the tie
so good wendy and this is a very common
struggle actually
sean and i talk about this so much
because as you know wendy
both of us are so multi-passionate we
want to start channels
all the time we're like yeah you know
what i could do i could get an editor i
could have someone help me with
thumbnails like i should start that
channel right we go down that road
exactly here's what i'd like you to do i
need you to put a date of commitment on
the calendar
because if you've tested all of them and
you like all of them
it actually just comes down to you have
to pick one
and what's gonna keep you stuck is not
choosing what's gonna keep you held back
from the greatness
that i know is inside of you wendy i
have known you for now
years now right like two years three
years yeah wendy
you're holding yourself back because
you're not committing to it so i need
you to put a commitment date on the
calendar and just say i'm picking this
one
i'm gonna go all in on this one and it
doesn't mean wendy
that in three years five years you know
10 years
you can shift into another season but i
want you to be known for
one thing first and remember you don't
have to be the expert wendy
you can just be the person one step
ahead interview the experts get them in
there
have them help right but you need to
make sure that
i know i i know your background so i'm
just kind of giving back around to the
think
marketing fam you're great at what you
do
you are versed in the things that you
study right
and so you have to actually just say you
know what i'm just committed to this
i'm all in i'm just gonna make this
happen and when i think about my
homeschool channel wendy i waited
three years to start that channel
three years i waited now was there
growth happening in that time
absolutely and that's what i think this
last couple years has been for you this
has been such
a university style like learning all the
things right you have
so much knowledge now it's actually time
to take action
and what we do is we have analysis
paralysis you are
analyzing this to the umph degree and i
know you
i know that you have it in you right now
but you're holding back on your
greatness
because of your lack of commitment so
put the date on your calendar
i want you to just choose one and i want
you to go all in on it
because you are so good at those things
that i know you're going to be
successful in it
and sometimes the fear of actually
committing to it
doesn't mean you can't do the other
things do a bible study
on facebook it's not your youtube
but sure if that's what you want like it
doesn't mean you can't do those other
things talk about health on your
instagram that's fine but we want
your we want to figure out what is your
youtube channel
right what are you actually going to be
known for on youtube how can you break
through
so you can talk about one thing now and
you can talk about 10 things later on
okay
so then how do you stay
the course once you've picked the thing
tell us the secret heather
you have to do this really dirty word
and it's called discipline
i know it's not the it's not like the
fun thing where i'm like here's the
productivity hack
it's discipline to stay focused okay
and there's actually no secret to
success other than
it's actually just being the person that
stays the course
like it really is a word that like we
don't like it is
self-discipline for me to not want to go
and start five new things right now it
is self-discipline
wendy i was not jazzed about doing
today's video
i i'm going on an rv trip tomorrow and
you and i know each other i'm leaving on
a girls rv trip tomorrow
i woke up this morning and i was like i
don't want to do think marketing live
i don't want to i don't want to shower
and get pretty i don't want to do
i want to go and work on my rv and then
i thought
and and of course i want to i should
record what i'm doing
maybe i should start a youtube channel
this is this is this morning wendy
right what i went through this morning i
was like i should just start a youtube
channel
i should just get an editor i should
just give vidcon i should like it's not
hard
and then the little bird right like
said that's not the mission right now
that's not the focus right now sure
later on if i want to start a youtube
channel after
there's so much money in this mission
that it funds the next one
that i can build a team around that that
i can build a team here that's
successful that we can
move forward on that but i didn't even
want to do this today
but i sat down i went through my routine
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
show
up right i'm gonna be so on fire i was
reading
all these motivational things this
morning i was reading i went into our
community and i was reading about their
success and i was like no i'm
recommitted
i got this i cannot wait to get online
today i am so fired up and excited to
help people choose their niche like
i had to get myself in that state
because there's days where you're like i
don't want to do this
right but i know that if i stay
committed to this
if i make another video and another
video and another video
that over time that library of content
is going to pay for itself the time that
i'm putting in today
is going to be 10 times more valuable
tomorrow
because i actually stayed disciplined
and committed
to that one thing and the doors of
possibility
will not open unless you stay
committed got it it's like an inevitable
weird thing that happens but it's like
you're
so close to literally the door the next
door opening
when you when you say this is who i am
this is what i'm showing up for this is
my channel this is the people these are
the people i'm gonna serve
all of a sudden these doors just start
to open and you're like oh my gosh why
why is this person asking me that oh
because they saw the 5 000 videos that i
did about
youtube so they're like she's the
youtube girl right
so i want you to stay committed wendy i
want you to know that it's discipline
it's perseverance it's linking arms with
people in our community
that are accountable and saying i'm
getting my video up by friday
i'm getting my video up by tuesday i'm
doing the thing and i'm going to keep
doing the thing
i'm going to keep grinding i'm going to
keep working on my craft and i'm going
to make this thing happen
does that help wendy yes it does thank
you so much heather
you're amazing uh can we shout out wendy
wendy where can they find you online
oh my social media handles are pastor
wendy coop
everywhere on social and then my youtube
channel is wendy coop
i love it thank you so much wendy for
being on today
man that word is not the word that
people want to hear
but i'm your coach right a coach and
when you think about like your football
coach
like i know football but when you think
about a football coach
man that football coach is in your face
that coach is saying drop down and give
me 20.
that coach is also in the locker room
encouraging you and that's what i want
to be for you i want to be someone that
is here saying if i can do this you can
do this too
but there's some things you're gonna
have to do you're gonna have to be
committed to the process
you're gonna have to be disciplined in
talking about the same
topic over and over and over you're
gonna have days like i had today
where i was like all i want to do is
something else
i don't want to talk about youtube and
then i got in my community
i got around the right people i set my
mind right and i was like no
i am in today i cannot wait to get
breakthrough for one person
if you are the one person right now who
just got breakthrough
on this live stream i did this for you
it's not about the 10
000 the 20 000 the million people i made
this video
for you and so i hope that helps you
when you think about staying committed
when you think about choosing your niche
when you're scared to actually make the
commitment for it
just know that the video that you're
creating the reason that you're doing
this
is to make lasting impact and change
in the world so i hope that helps you i
hope that that gives you some uh some
insight
i'm going to take a drink of water
melissa is going to ask tell me who the
next
person is and that is
brandon is coming in hey brandon how you
doing
hey i'm good how are you good um tell us
who you are what your channel is about
and my question is
sure uh my name is brandon boyd i host
the brain and boyd show
very creative name on youtube and the
channel
started out focusing mostly on personal
finance but is more niched down into
credit card reviews and benefits rewards
travel hacking things like that
and one of my questions is i've actually
got a couple my question is
we're at the point right now where we're
trying to focus on do we
make content that is more well produced
funny entertaining that's different than
the regular
credit card niche we try to i think a
lot of it's boring just personally if
i'm watching it so i'm like do i put all
this extra effort in
and do cards you know two days a week or
do i put out
shorter videos that are less edited less
slick
i guess would be the word to say and get
them out more frequently because i'm
trying to grow my subscriber base
just trying to figure out kind of what
to do there yeah okay so
a couple things i'm seeing one like can
we just congratulate
i mean we're at oh that's not me but i
would love those numbers oh okay i was
like wow look at you go
i would totally take that i mean i was
like that's not credit card niche so
let's see okay
uh credit card uh the brandon boyd show
i think if you just search that it would
probably pop up okay
sorry well i mean let's shout out let's
shot our competitors right that's
someone with you and we just started
this
channel in later september beginning of
october so we're
very new and if you look at my first
videos we started out with
you know personal finance talking about
ways to cut expenses money and stuff
like that
and then we've expanded and seen better
numbers
with credit cards and people you know
looking into rewards and stuff like that
so we've had a few videos reach over a
thousand
you know just on those without any
promotion or anything so i'm just
wondering
do i focus on these edits the inserts of
the pop culture clips and all these
funny
moments whereas when i see other people
in the niche they're
just sitting in front of a camera
talking and it looks like it would save
me about
75 percent of my time working yeah
yeah do you have the time to do those
edits are you doing this editing
yourself this is
like two camera angles tell me about
your team
well my team is my wife and i okay great
hey that's a team
right she works a lot you know we have
the ideas for the videos but she focuses
a lot on the layout of the videos i
focus more on
obviously the front of camera the
inserting the clips and editing
so between the two of us we crank out a
video our goal is about every five days
amazing you know i see some channels
that are putting up stuff every other
day
no you know what i mean yeah yeah so
really great so your question is should
you be
you know inserting some more making this
more of an edutainment channel right
meaning you're inserting the
entertainment
and the education all in one is that
correct right i just want to make it
more accessible but that was my whole
goal was to make it more accessible to
people
and more fun but i don't know if i'm
overworking myself unnecessarily you
know what i mean it's um
it's a tough call yeah i would say um
have you been
experimenting with it at all or is this
just an idea
i'm afraid to be because what we've done
is worked somewhat but we're only three
or three or four months in so i'm almost
afraid to
try something new because what's worked
is doing well we're getting new subs
every day
and you know you get a little bit of
afraid to branch out because something's
working
yes oh this is such a good new creator
struggle right here and
and season creators i mean think about
every time we do something new on think
media we have a million subscribers
we've been doing the same thing for
years and we're like
should we try this new thing we just
tried a new thing we're like let's make
this type of video let's do this type of
thing
so um here's what i want you to know um
you yes experiment
try new things maybe do it vloggy style
do it this way
do it talking head whatever allows you
to maybe just get more creative with
where you think you can reach your
audience
i say try it there's nothing wrong with
here's the difference
you're not shifting your entire content
style
you're experimenting with a couple
episodes
and when you can put it in those guard
rails of like it's okay
to try and test something new i think
that this is such a great niche
to be able to insert pop culture things
i think this is
i think adding entertainment to help
someone watch a seven minute video
is the right thing to do right and so
when you say i'm just kind of scared
because this is working
you're in your first year of being a
creator on the chain
on the uh platform this is your time to
experiment
because as you get larger and larger and
larger
it gets even more nerve-wracking to try
and shift
a type of content that you're doing but
i
am for the um i am for the idea that
youtube is about like it's for you
to be creative you're still within the
same niche
you're talking to the same audience like
you're talking about the same topics
all you're doing is just putting a new
coat of paint on the cool car
right so i would say for sure
try and do some experimenting now if
here's where the breaking point happens
if you start doing this new style
it's getting about the same amount of
views you're not seeing an increase in
the thing and it's taking three times as
long to edit
well then you're like that experiment is
not the way we want to go
but what if you tried that and all of a
sudden that became the video that popped
off with 200 000 views
well now we know that dang i'm glad i
tried it because
now that video is the one that's that's
getting more traction
right so i just want to encourage you
that brandon you're doing a great job
this already is looking so great um just
keep at it you're at the beginning
stages
of a baby youtube channel if you stay
committed to this process for the next
one year three years five years you will
be someone
that has major influence in this market
awesome
yeah i'm new to the show here as well so
i'm trying to pick up as much as i can
before i jump off would you say the same
too with branching out of your niche i
mean
you know i'm in a certain area right now
how do you know when it's time to make
the move do you
wait till you hit a certain number of
subscribers is it a certain amount of
time you're on there or do you just
like you said experiment and try
something else
yeah so right now what you're doing is
you're going deep in
one topic in an actual niche
so when you say branch out are you like
trying to switch to like buying homes
like real estate are you trying to
switch to like well that's part of it i
am a licensed real estate agent too so
part of me is like hey be great show
somebody how to do a first time
home buying purchase it would be great
to talk about investing
uh budgeting all these things that i
have knowledge in but i'm afraid if i go
too broad that i'm going to confuse the
audience and
people won't know what to expect when
they open my videos you know
yes and so right now i would say get
really good at this like get really good
at this part this is a
this is a niche like the whole credit
card thing is a niche and it doesn't
mean
later on you can't talk about it there's
no necessarily set time and i would say
your niche is investing
right like that's how i would i would
view your niche is investing
um there's there's always the idea that
you can
always be testing so maybe throw out a
video that
is around that but it's through the lens
of investing
right i wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily
go totally down real estate
and then all of a sudden you're talking
about credit cards that can be kind of
jarring
right but if you're under the same
umbrella if it's
if it's like we talk about lighting and
we also talk about
um you know iphone editing
they're around the same thing they're
all about creating youtube videos
so what is the value proposition of your
channel that's what i would just start
to get more clear on
my value proposition as i want i want to
help people um you know
live a financially free life okay well
what does that mean what are some of the
topic buckets underneath that
that are cohesive but not too um
sideways does that make sense yep it
does yeah yeah you got this brandon
thanks so much for being a part of the
think fam
uh super excited for your journey and i
can't wait to see what happens on
youtube for you this year absolutely
i'll be following you guys thanks
awesome that was amazing can we give it
up for
brandon for that amazing i am gonna
check out your channel
because i'm like i'm still trying to
figure out this whole like credit card
hacking thing i have no clue
but i know it's like a whole thing so i
am super
excited for that hey if you're getting
value make sure you hit that like button
i've got
james up next james is here how are you
doing
hey how are you heather i am so excited
you're here
uh thank you tell everyone who you are
and my question is yeah so um my name is
james hume and i
am a worship pastor and i'm also someone
that struggles with depression
and um i started a youtube channel about
nine months ago
and really is a way to kind of encourage
people um through music but
also wanting to relate to them in terms
of the mental health struggle that so
many
struggle with and so uh my my question
is kind of two-fold one you mentioned
about how to
solve a problem and so for someone like
me that does a lot of
covers musically uh how do you solve a
problem
in that sense and then i've been
thinking specifically about
niching down to calling my channel like
depressed
christian and uh i've seen a
ton of facebook groups that deal with
christians that have depression
so i know there's a market out there for
it uh i haven't seen as much
on the youtube side there are a number
of videos that have done
really well that talk about christians
with depression but
just trying to figure out how to
navigate that does that make sense
oh makes total sense james what is your
current channel right now
uh just type in james hume i'm like the
top five videos
in the search okay there we go
what a beautiful family omg let me bring
this up so everyone can see
okay so um a couple things you said one
you said you know i'm doing
music um i'm doing covers and then i
also want to do this other thing
yeah we see it as like that's the same
it's actually two different things okay
so
so going so it doesn't and here's where
i here's
lean in for this james just because you
go down the route
of christians with depression or
depressed christian
doesn't mean that one of the answers
isn't worship music
does that make sense so that's the
chocolate covered carrot that's the like
how do i get six pack abs my want is
six-pack abs i'm not searching
how do i only drink celery juice right
like does that make sense like i mean
people do search that
as people do search worship music so
those are actually
two separate things the ant one of one
of the answers
in that depressed christian um niche
that you would be in
is worship music so i would either
separate out your worship music onto
something else
i would keep it as just something you do
personally i would whatever that looks
like
but if you're going down the route of
what is the problem you solve
you help christians that are struggling
with mental illness
that is a very wide niche that
definitely needs a leader
in that space and where you can join
arms with people who are already
speaking
into that space so um so your question
is
how do you how do you do it yeah i mean
you know i i think what you're saying
makes a lot of sense i i
part of the issue that i've had is
whether or not this is too convoluted to
have two concepts
happening in one channel uh and um so
yeah
i think you've already answered that
that that's super helpful yeah and i
would be asking
if you're in that that's that was you're
already in the groups which is amazing
you're already a part of that
you're already living it so you know
maybe what you're searching for
what books do people need what podcasts
who can you interview
what are you know what are um the the
five steps what are people searching and
how can you be the answer on the other
side of that
and then remembering that um you know
there are uh
covert christian channels and there are
overt
christian channels my friend pedro adeo
teaches this
the idea that if you're like i am a
christian channel i
only help christians this is what i do
that is
an overtly christian channel yeah
they're also covertly christian channels
think media sean and i are both
believers our
principles in how we how we act and the
way we
do our lives we just live and breathe
our christian values
yeah we're not overtly on our channel
saying we only help christian youtubers
right we'll help anyone who wants to
hurt youtube
but you will also hear us you know
quoting our favorite scriptures you'll
also hear me say like i'm a woman of
faith and i am
praying that people see the light on
youtube like
that's okay for me to say and i'm old in
that conviction
but i'm not also just saying i will only
help you
if you're a christian we even on our
team we have
muslim on our team we have atheists on
our team like but
i personally am going to live my values
through my youtube channel
and i hope that that becomes a light for
other mothers for other homeschoolers
for other people who want to join that
journey and i just
live the principle and i'm going to be
an overtly i'm going to be a covert
christian youtube channel so does that
help i mean that's pretty bold i don't
know like we're on
i'm bold right now but i don't know
james that
it's possible to speak into a
group of people that maybe it the the
specialty is christian
depression but maybe mental illness
altogether you know like it could be
that
you're just gonna bring the answer of
jesus
you know yep so that that is
lights out good so thank you for that
that for those of us because i know that
i'm not the only one there's a number of
people that have
music covers for their channel how how
do you
you know explain how the best way to
create
you know a channel that solves problems
besides just you know
music covers that does that make sense
yeah
um you want to answer specific questions
so your next task is to go and figure
out what are people
actually typing in the search bar you
know
how to deal with depression
and anxiety and loneliness as a
christian
right are you seeing what i'm seeing
right here yeah after a breakup right
i'm i'm talking more about not in terms
of the mental health side just having a
channel that does music covers
how you just want to go down the music
cover i didn't want to do the mental
health i just wanted to do music covers
how do i solve a problem
uh you would be in the entertainment
space and
that the that is where talent
trumps everything yes and that is and so
you ride current trends i would know
what are the newest songs that are
coming out
i would be you know doing the cover i'd
be making shorts
i would be um i would be figuring out
what other people
are are doing i would give your own
aspect of it but like you
whenever you go into the entertainment
space on youtube
it's not the algorithm it's the talent
and it's becoming discoverable just
through the talent
on your channel so it's making sure
you've got good covers
you know like your thumbnail matters
yeah your title like i love how you're
using emojis that's great
but it really comes down to the talent
if you're doing music and you're like i
want to do music music then
talent has to trump everything
absolutely okay
awesome james thank you thank you so
much today that was amazing thank you
all right so we are going i just went
down like a whole rabbit hole so james
gets all the tips today if you're
getting value
hit the like button right now i don't
even know how many likes we're at but
let's get a hundred more how about that
yeah i think that's a good idea all
right so who do we have up next
uh let's see melissa has um
uh oh here we go uh vashna how you doing
hey um actually it's advice now but um
oh it's totally fine
so close it's okay beautiful get it with
practice
who you are and my question is yes
um so my name is my channel name is
handmade by vaishna
but um my channel name is still kind of
my name so still working that out
i am currently um
an arts and college youtuber i used to
do lifestyle but i'm
trying to i guess rebrand for 2021
and beyond so still working on that
um i i have posted i guess
about 15
videos ish and i've been definitely
trying to take into consideration
a lot of the tips that you guys have
given on this channel and even on your
main channel and it's definitely helped
um improve the watch retention um
at the beginning so i keep peop i
definitely have
kept people going but sorry going back
to the question
um regarding like niching and stuff
so as you can see i'm both an arts and
college youtuber
and i definitely see niche combos work
but i'm just like
i'm definitely gonna keep some sort of
like
personal part of my channel on since i
am going into the medical field
or like the healthcare field so i really
want to still keep that so people can
see oh this is actually what i really do
but i still want to keep the art because
that's really why i started the channel
so my question is is there a way for me
to like find the intersection between
the two to still
somehow keep both of these viewers on my
channel because i've definitely been
seeing like
an up and down spiral i mean up and down
like
wave um like when i post like an art
video
i end up losing like someone who's
probably into like the college
when i post a college video i end up
losing someone who's like into the art
so it's just like
i will i just love these two so much and
i i don't want to
just do art like
i just i don't want to just do art
because i just feel like i'll be
i won't be able to show like like a more
personal side of myself
so yeah i know that it's a lot but
i mean that's how i feel yeah and you
know
this is a really great question this
idea like can you combine
two niches um the answer is yes
you could combine two niches um
however these two like like
nerd fitness that's combining like two
like that's like when you dress up like
like a spider-man and you go and work
out that's like
like a comic fitness right um you can
combine those two
there's a couple things that you said
that i want this would be value for the
whole audience
um you said that you know when you post
those college videos
you're losing subscribers because that's
not what they signed up for if they
signed up for art videos
right or if you post you post our videos
you'll lose subscriber because
people are showing up for the college
things um
a way that you could put these two
things together
um is not actually on youtube
like there's nothing that says on
instagram
stories you're not sharing your
day-to-day life as a college student
and artist like that's a combo right
the thing about youtube though that we
have to recognize is we have to play in
the sandbox of youtube
and youtube is all about helping
get your videos in front of the right
people it's not against us like the
algorithm is not against us the
algorithm is
for us but it's only for us if we play
in the sandbox of youtube
meaning that you're you are creating two
different audiences just because they
like college doesn't mean
that they like art which is different
than
um say brandon who was on a little
earlier he
was he's making things about credit
cards right he's talking about like the
points and the credit card system
it's not actually a far reach if he
starts talking about
real estate investing at the same time
because that person who would be
interested in credit card hacking
is also interested in saving money and
using money in other ways
same type of psychology of the person
who's subscribing to your platform
so it's not that you can't the the niche
that would be together would be college
artists
that's the niche if you decide to put
those two things together it's
college artists so it's speaking to a
smaller niche which is not always a bad
thing
but it's how do you reach them and how
are you helping them right
so it's not that you can't combine them
but i need you to take some time and
actually just decide what do you want
why are you creating this youtube
channel and on to what what would you
like it to provide for you
what's the reason behind it what's the
why behind it
and that doesn't mean that if you are
only putting art on here
that you also can't be a successful
doctor
or nurse or wherever you're going like
that that doesn't like
because i share homeschool things on my
homeschool channel
doesn't mean that i'm not a successful
businesswoman
i'm just not necessarily sharing that on
that channel right
so i hope that gives a little bit of
context you can
the niche would be college artists that
doesn't mean that it's not that bad but
what happens after that and where does
it go after that right so i would just
be thinking about that
and just choosing one maybe it is all
about maybe you're like you know what i
i like art because art is just a hobby
and i really want to go deep on helping
people
uh learning how to go through medical
school and and you know
after that how do you get a job and how
do you grow practice and you know
whatever that evolution of that
that channel would be and you just let
me the hobby or
you say i'm going to go all in and art's
going to be my side hustle
while i'm in medical school and so i'm
going to just do art and youtube and
be super creative and have that outlet
while i'm doing this other thing but you
don't have
you can share in your videos that you're
an art school you could share on your
instagram you can make igtvs
you know there's a lot of other ways
that you can incorporate that but i hope
that gives some clarity on
how do you double niche that would be
your double niche
or you actually just pick one or the
other does that help
okay yeah it definitely does and that
doesn't mean
i don't have to share those videos like
once in a while like
yeah this is like actually my life
exactly and you just have to know
that you're sharing that video
because it's fun and because it's just a
part of your creativity
and know though that you might lose
subscribers because that's not what they
signed up for or
you might get to the point where you
gain enough influence that people are
like
heck yeah i want to see what happens all
day long how i didn't know you were an
artist
and you're in medical school that's
amazing right like
it can it can work if you want to just
throw those up every now and then and
it's a life update and you're just
talking about who you are and what
you're doing
just don't have the expectation that
that video is going to go viral
or if that video does go viral and then
people aren't subscribing well you know
why
it's not the intent of your channel you
just decided to put up a video
out of alignment with intent does that
make sense
yeah for sure thank you so much so much
for being on
that was so much fun what a great
channel she is a really great artist
definitely go over and check her out if
you have uh
some time and you want to check out uh
some cool card making
um over there i've got a couple more
people in the back right now
you are watching the think marketing
show
and if you want to uh go to
the next thing after this video it's
gonna be our free
youtube class that we have over at
thinkmasterclass.com
that's going to be the next place for
you to go thinkmasterclass.com
let me know in the chat have you taken
that class did you watch that class
because thousands of creators have gone
through and watched this class and their
channels
are growing we get emails and dms and
messages
all the time that are like think media i
can't believe that this channel and you
did the thing you said to do this
in the class and it's yeah so think
masterclass
dot com is your next place to go
and let me go here and next up we have
oliver oliver's coming on hey oliver how
you doing
hey heather can you hear me fine that
sounds amazing yes your microphone is
epic uh can you let me know who you are
where you are from and my question is
sure so yeah my name is oliver i'm from
helsinki finland and
my channel is called road to finish
and my mission is to help international
students
get a university degree and start their
early careers in finland
and a bit of backstory super quickly
before my question so
uh i i basically went full time on my
channel last september when i had around
2500 subscribers which again i think
shows the power of finding a niche that
can be actually monetized
and uh i'm currently working on my first
paid course
uh specifically on job hunting in
finland with the help of an
old colleague who has almost 10 years of
experience in recruiting an hr
and we're working currently on the on
the course videos and the marketing
strategy and
we should launch the course somewhere
you know within the last
or the next two months and so my
question considering the amount of
experience that you guys have
in building paid courses both
pre-recorded
and and alive what are some of the
biggest stumbling blocks and mistakes
that
you you guys have made that we should be
aware of before we actually launch our
our first course wow what a
really great question um i love that
you're at that stage
i love that you're going all in this is
like classic
youtube success right here so i just
first want to honor you and congratulate
you for being at this level
and going all in on that a couple things
we learned is that um
getting success stories really matters
so when you're doing this course um
maybe even before you do it
i would do maybe a pre-launch that is at
a lower cost
that is only to say 50 people
20 people 10 people at that like super
low rate
uh because you want to be gaining
testimonies you want to be getting that
success story out of your course
because you can try and sell your course
as much as you want but there's nothing
better than
someone else saying i took their course
and this is the success that i got from
it
and it doesn't have to be massive
success it can be
very specific things so when you're
gaining testimonials you want to make
sure that people are saying before
i took this course this is how i was how
i felt where i was in life whatever the
before was and then after i
after i took the course i felt like this
people want to know how they're going to
feel after um they want to know
the the specific thing i was able to
x y and z for us at think media it was i
was able to start my channel
and i got to my first 1000 subscribers
now have we helped people get to
200 000 300 000 500 000 absolutely
but there's something so good about just
knowing that oh they're they're
just one step ahead of me i can do that
right so testimonials is huge that's one
thing i would say so figuring out how
you can get a test group
in there first um we always start when
we're when we're doing our courses
we always start at a lower price and
then as we update the course
as we add value we are always increasing
the price
because the value is increasing as we're
going
until we hit a really good sweet spot in
the market where we know
we're about you know right level with
the people that we are in
industry with uh we know the results
that people are getting we know what the
actual um value of that course is
we're able to do that and then thirdly
whenever you're selling a course we're
getting so deep here so if you're part
of think marketing
this is your advanced phd stuff no it's
not but this is how i feel
um when you're selling your course
you want to make sure that you have um
some type of bonuses
so that you have some urgency to your
offer
um one of our uh one of the teachers and
mentors that we had is chalene johnson
she has an academy called marketing
impact academy
um it's a really great academy you can
actually you can go to miabonus.com we
have bonuses to that academy
and in her academy she teaches
like the five steps of making sure that
your offer sells because your
course is its own thing your offer
is a different thing the course is the
actual product
but the offer that you're making someone
is its own
thing so you want to have some bonuses
wrapped around your
offer that can be taken away right like
you can't just like take away the course
you don't want to necessarily just be
like and that's it you want to have an
offer that allows for people to have
some
urgency to purchase so when we so
we just had a challenge at the end of
our challenge we uh
we invited people to go deeper with us
inside of our academy
video ranking academy which we sell all
the time
all day long as just the academy but
when you
actually took the offer when you went
through our our um
when you went through our challenge and
you you
wanted to go deeper it was video ranking
academy and
we gave you some special bonuses for
free so that
that gave urgency as to why you should
buy now
right because we sell it online three
thousand dollars all the time
but you could get a discount and a bonus
when we did that specific offer
that went away so those are just a
couple things
we can go so much deeper but i really
recommend um just having some good
testimonials some success
knowing that the course will always need
to be updated right you should always be
thinking about how can i update it give
some new downloads and new things into
the course
and then figure out what offer you want
to wrap around it and then the best part
is
is that you're going to experiment with
different offers at different price
points to figure out what works for you
in the market
exactly super quickly just uh absolutely
really really great
points and i have to write this down
after after watching the replay but uh
one one question uh to to one of the
topics that you spoke about about the
pricing points
i hope you don't mind uh me asking how
do you actually test out the different
pricing points do you have a software
behind the door or do you simply just
change the pricing point points uh for
example by using discounts or
yep yeah so we know that we will not
sell our academy for less than a certain
price we've just established that
because
we've done market research on to know
what are the other academies out there
what are other people in our industry
selling for um about the same amount of
context
with this person and about the same
amount of context so we want to be
um priced within our market um
we are a premium course also so we
provide
an enormous amount of support and
ongoing um
education and so that allows us to be
even more premium
in our market space we're not just one
and done you just buy something
from us and you never hear from us we
like we're the suffocating parents that
like
you come home for thanksgiving and we
like love on you like crazy right so we
have premium priced our products because
i want to love on everyone in our
academy
and so we've done we started in the
market knowing that this was
we will never sell it lower than this
amount and then what we do is we
increase our price and we test that
offer we increase our price we test that
offer and so we just kind of know
now through just testing and market
research
and we keep track of all of that on our
own spreadsheets um how many people
bought it
what was the offer um what did people at
we do um
intro interviews so like you know when
did you start
how what what made you buy you know we
ask our
our actual customers these questions and
then we then have that data
when we move forward so you want to go
and you want to look at what else is
priced in your market around that
um and then decide are you premium are
you going to provide better service
you're going to be better at what all
the things
are you lower cost you want it to be
quick and easy and fast you want to put
it on udemy
for 10 bucks you know or do you want it
to be 297
in the market for whatever that looks
like there are books however that do
talk about pricing online seven
at the end is a very good number um it
it it's like a psychological thing like
look up like
online pricing and you'll notice even
things in store are like 4.99
well because four is the first number
you see you don't see five right so it's
just understanding what that looks like
i hope that helps i'm just going down a
rabbit hole because i can geek out on
this stuff
but thank you so much oliver for your
question super interesting and
just a really quick shout out for you
guys once again just
again for everyone listening i was able
to go full time leave my
nine to five uh with 2500 subscribers
that's
absolutely nothing uh using brand deals
and and
you know as you as you guys speak but
speak about all the time have a plan
before you start and
and especially consider the monetization
because that is going to be
the key for you to to make this into a
full-time job if that's something that
you want
again thanks so much heather really
really valuable thank you so much oliver
go back and re-watch this because i was
dropping some golden nuggets and all of
that
um and we go deeper into that in things
like our mastermind and all of those
type of things but
i would definitely check out mia
bonus.com because
um that we have special bonuses to an
offer
that is gonna help so uh just a way to
show you um
some things that we have for you so
thank you so much oliver okay
thank you so much for being a part of
the think marketing
show today hey make sure you hit that
like button
make sure you let me know in the
comments down below question of the day
what niche are you in i want to know i
want to see all the people inside of our
think community
share the niches that they're in um i
think what's so amazing about youtube is
all the amount of creativity
and the ways that people are allowed to
use their gifts and talents to help
people online
thank you so much for watching and you
can click or tap the screen
right now to go to the next video if
you're watching live on facebook thank
you so much for being here
youtube you're awesome and i'll catch
you in the next video
bye